out to try give it some love good
okay team uh welcome to today's um
council meeting 31st of October and
welcome to those that are uh watching
and on live stream couple of bits of
housekeeping for you um I have one main
minor uh late item which doesn't require
a motion but it just relates to the um
pending naming of the Tisbury collection
facility so just a bit of an update on
that and where the uh the time frames
that are coming doesn't require any
decision- making by Council and the
other issue is the issue of uh tab 11
which was a paper regarding parks and
reserves management and the disposal of
land and three attachments and I've
elected to leave that report and the
three appendices on the table at the
stage while I worked through some um
issues with the chief executive about
how we might get some um advice on on
how we deal with the disposal of the
land uh given that we have Donovan Park
as a significant disposal and that we
also have uh eight of 16 Parcels of land
that we're about to dispose of are
actually reserves as well so how we deal
with them we need some
advice on the reserves act so uh we're
just going to leave those reports on the
table at this stage until we get that
advice so that we're not heading down
the wrong
track just
move report oh sorry yes and you will
have gathered by Rec recent updates to
your records that we have a major light
item which is the annual report which
Patricia will talk to shortly as we get
there um so at this stage I only have
apologies from Council of bond and a
less one from
Alex Barry move thank you thank you the
same two again um we have Nobi in public
forum so if we just like to work through
our ways through the uh
we need to uh also move to the uh major
late item which is the annual
report thank you no too late it's always
it's always defaulted to those those
twins so um so we just work our way
through the uh minutes of the meetings
that we need to do so the first one is
the minute of the risk and insurance
committee held on the 19th of September
move that Mr May seconded thank you uh
any discussion about
those there being none U all those in
favor I carried minutes of the meeting
of council held on the 26th of September
I'll move chair yeah thank
you than Grant uh any discussion on
those there being none all those in
favor I carried minutes of the meeting
of the committee wellbeing committee
held on the 10th of October move that
they be received yes thank you second
and
second yeah Peter thank you uh any
discussion on
those there being none all that's in
favor carried minutes of the meeting of
the infrastructure committee held on the
uh 10th of October and we have uh a
recommendation two recommendations in
relation to that yeah I will move the
minutes and also the recommendations
thank you r a second right thank you any
discussion about those or the
recommendations
no okay um all those in favor hi carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
Council on the 17th of
October move that yeah thank you
automatically the partner any discussion
about those they being none all those in
favor carried uh the minutes of the
finance and projects committee held on
the 17th of October thank you you grant
yeah second and Tom thank you any
discussion around
that no this is easy work all those in
favor I carried the risk and insurance
committee held on the 25th of October
move that thank you I
second thank you any discussion on
those right all those in favor carried
uh tab 11 which is the parks lands
disposal options master plan and
management plans update uh is currently
sitting on the table so we don't need to
go to that at this stage the next one is
the long-term plan climate
change oh sorry Rihanna for you to
speak y May how are you very good thank
you right do you want me to just speak
briefly to the report
certainly um so councilors you'll be
aware that um we've been working with
environment South and in T Mama at a
regional level um this paper brings some
more detail to yourself around specific
um options that we can include for um
consultation in the long-term plan um it
also brings forward to you the second
calculation of council's um emissions um
the first Baseline we did was very much
an exploratory piece of work it was done
over the period of lockdown and so um
there has been a change with this
profile but we have had
um so so there's some good information
there in terms of areas where we've
actually made quite a bit of progress um
so you'll note within the report there a
recommendation to consider for the
long-term plan to introduce an internal
contestable fund to continue that good
work in emissions reduction um it really
is probably the advice of officers at
this point that we have probably picked
that lwh hanging fruit and we're going
to need um to make more investment if
the council chooses that it wishes to
move further on that and we' also like
guidance on whether you wish to have a
more ambitious nit zero Target and again
that's something that we can then um
lias with our regional um Partners
on I've put forward a suggestion for you
for an ltp indicator on carbon emissions
reduction it's recommended this is quite
a new complex area that we include that
outside the statement of service
performance but it's a good way of being
able to communicate to the public um how
we are doing I've set there a um
suggested initial 5% reduction Target as
potentially quite achievable and again
that's for your
consideration also noting that we still
believe that um on the adaptation front
that it would be useful and we do need
to invest further in understanding the
asset condition data or some of our key
assets and again we would work
regionally on that um and also finally
there are some points that we recommend
being made to central government as they
work on that area of
adaptation um so mayor I'm not sure if
the deputy mayor as the lead um for ICC
at that Regional level wants to say
anything but I'm happy to take any
questions sure I've got a couple to
start with Ranna um
uh one is in the early part of the
summary there you talk about adaptation
or and managed Retreat do we have any
obvious um areas in our city where um a
managed Retreat is actually um already
known or are we more dealing with
adaptation we we need to we need to
understand further and that's where we
need to have that modeling um liar is
just the first stage before we can
really give an answer to that question
sure so begs a second question out of
that then um we've been asking for a
long time for the liar information out
of environment Southland and the
modeling that goes with it um so I guess
that that impacts
um
um our impact from our Rivers I guess in
particular is of interest and and
whether there are areas of risk because
of the potential for flooding and how we
would deal that be it adaption or some
pot Cal management Retreat um is there
any inl on the horizon from environment
sou to say when that will be
available so the liar data is available
now some of it's been utilized by
Council for example in the Sandy Point
piece of work however you're correct in
saying that further modeling is required
before we can really make best use of
that data um environment South has given
a pathway forward and they have indeed
started on some of that flood R risk
modeling um planning that project
um so it is quite a few years of work
that is needed um so it hopefully will
be something we can consider for the
next long-term plan sure and just one
one I've got people just one one other
question um and I'm not sure whether
you're party to the previous Workshop we
just had today in relation to Sandy
Point um but there was um significant
discussion around um offsetting our
carbon footprint for one of a bit words
um with increased forestry uh at Sandy
Point and potentially the um increase of
the planting of native trees which we
set ourselves a target of 50,000 a few
years ago and are currently sitting
around the 20,000 Mark and in light of
that the potential for both those two uh
do we in your view still need the
200,000 annual contestable fund which is
an internal contestable fund
so you know would those initiatives
around planting trees go far enough that
we um don't need to have a contestable
fund to offset
further so um as this report says
including the the memo that's attached
to it from the forestry Consultants
there is if you chose to offset
emissions through forestry there is
quite a significant number of trees that
would need to be planted every year um
and that is something that does take
time as you say the parks team are
currently about 20,000 trees in um and
that was initially going to be a
three-year project that was delayed by
Co um that 50,000 trees give or take a
few thousand is approximately what you'd
have to plan to offset every year of
council scope one two and three
emissions um and it but I think I guess
I can't answer that question
specifically because more work is needed
to be done um it's really important that
the right tree is planted in the right
place and that we work with our partners
including T MMA um to really understand
what that looks like um I would suggest
that the internal contestable fund is a
sensible option in terms of um enabling
that flexibility for the resources to be
spent in different
ways okay thank you
Tom I'll try to the sent your question
but the the um I mean the point is that
the
$200,000 is been spent to try to reduce
our gross
emissions and the further that we can
reduce those then the less we have to
plant out and if if you look at the cost
of each of those two things I mean we to
make decisions about whether um it's
better to you know mitigate through um
changing a technology or whether it's
better to mitigate through planting
trees but the point of the $200,000 I
think is to try to get our gross
emissions down weit about 95,000 tons of
scope 1 2 and three um carbon emissions
a year um I I think just looking at what
makes that up that we should probably be
able to have that if we uh in terms of
gross emissions if we um if we do that
then rather than have to plant out 1100
hectares which is half the area 7 point
then we'd only have to plant out 500
hectares which is um you know sounds a
more manageable number so the two things
go together actually yeah yeah thank you
here
rangy um there's um a mention of the
savings at Splash Palace
of uh saving 2,000 tons of carbon
emissions uh what is it now that's
obviously what we've Saed can tell me
someone tell me what Splash Palace is
poking out
please is that one for you we we we must
know because we'd have to work out the
2000 somehow um so just to clarify the
2,000 is the initial estimate of the
annual savings that was done at the time
of the installation of the project there
is details within the um appendex of the
um calculation of emissions of Splash
Palace um if if councilors are
interested looking at that specific
amount obviously wood energy still emits
a significant amount of emissions it's
just a lot less than the previous thank
thanks that that leads to my next
question is why do why don't we go
electric because that there are electric
um heating systems for swimming pools
and then there'll be zero emissions
because our electricity is produced
either out of Roxboro Clyde you name it
windmills so why why don't we go
elri um so through you chair we could
explore that and that might be something
that the internal contestable fund if a
good project was put forward could
explore that I think it's worth noting
that there are still emissions from our
electricity even though it's renewable
because of the way that the emissions
are calculated and including the impact
of the whole Nationwide Network so
that's just something to consider as
well
okay just that you know like it's quite
considerable I mean I can probably
answer it you know now is it's going to
cost a a heap
more than wood chips so that brings me
to the section of the Local Government
Act section 14 and it says that a local
Authority should undertake any
commercial transaction in in accordance
with Sound business practices so where
do we how do we how do we feed that into
our policy where
in one direction we're heading to save
the planet yet the Local Government Act
is telling us no you got to you got to
spend your money sensibly and the best
practice and best practice may not mean
that you're um you know you're saving
your carbons and doing that you're
actually doing the best practice so how
does that fit in how does this policy
actually morph and the same with our
30-year infrastructure strategy how does
that fit into that that we're actually
doing the infrastructure strategy in a
in a way that um off offsets
carbon um so I think you the the most
important thing would be obviously that
the internal contestable fund would need
to be set up to consider all those
things because you're absolutely correct
council is responsible for considering
all aspects of community well-being um
and you have to consider all those
factors in making investment decisions
um so for example one of the reasons
that Council has invested in hybrid
vehicles um primarily over electric
vehicles is so that during an emergency
should they be required we can make sure
we can operate them if for some reason
the electricity network is down so
that's one reason behind that decision
that's just one example of course the
cost of things needs to be weighed
up think if I can step in here sure if
you go to page 114 of board books um is
the part of the inventory report that
shows the comparison and those different
types of emissions and electricity is
still
1213 whatever that measure is I think
it's tons yeah um from purchase
electricity where the wood chips is
712 doesn't make any sense
doesn't make any sense CH can I explain
it because sure thank you be helpful so
you get in terms of how accounting is
done for carbon you get charged at
whatever the grid factor is as they call
it and the grid factor is that if say
15% of New Zealand's electricity is
coming from coal or gas say then you get
charged 15% it doesn't make any
difference if we hanging on the end of
manipuri makes no difference so you so
that's the way you because the idea is
that the whole of the country is in a
big electric cycle and it might be that
sometimes you're actually getting
electricity from the north isand so you
get charged at whatever's called The
Grid Factor the Ty does the same thing
you get Char even though it's linked to
manri they still get charged about 15%
for no I mean that's actually good and
that's the reason it's different that's
the reason still so it actually proves
there's no science behind
this okay Grant
yeah so just just a couple of clarifying
points so with the the contestable fund
that would be linked to try to reduce
the carbon by the 5% cumul over the 3
years is
that is that what or would that be in
addition so we'd create the $200,000
fund and in addition to that we'd look
to drive some further emissions so we're
getting we could get more than the
495 tons that the 5% is cumulatively
over 3 years is
that I'm not sure where the numbers come
from but the point of the $2,000 is to
try to reduce the emissions in the most
efficient way yeah so so basically of
Michael's team you know they would bid
in for that yeah right and if somebody's
got a really good idea to reduce X tons
for only
y then you know that that they'd be able
to execute that project that the actual
objective if if we take 2050 as our
objective for a Net Zero yeah then if
you if you count you know through the
next 27 years and you get it then I
don't know if that's 3 or 4% a year but
basically who's in here would get you
there by 2050 right what what's the
question it's asked ran and asked
another part of this is whether we
should try to do it
quicker can do it slower because the
country's committed to 20 but we could
do it faster if we were to committed
doing it faster then we' need hockey
stick it or else we need increase that
you know percentage to match the earlier
time date personally my view is that we
should aim for probably 2040 rather than
2050 um cuz it's an awful lot easier for
us for us than it is for most other
parts of the yeah carg I may what I was
trying to understand is you know we'd be
ambitious if we say we want the 5%
cumulative reductions over 3 years and
the $200,000 fund is to add to that
which would shorten it up it's to help
achieve that at faster rate so it would
infect yeah it wouldn't affect
to so we end up with cumulatively more
than as it means by which you achieve it
so the $2,000 would be identify the best
way to achieve that 5% plus 2% yeah I
mean I think that's pretty modest
personally you could set a higher Target
but if you set a higher Target you would
bring forward the date by which you're
going to get to zero which I think would
be actually the great thing for us to do
yeah I suppose my concern is that we we
put the $200,000 fund and and then we we
just go for the real easy targets that
were there anyway and so we've just paid
for that and I work out there's a about
a 6.7 year return on that 200,000 at the
current Saving right if we value cabinet
60 bucks which it is so I think and it's
a little bit to Tom's point I think we
need to be a bit more ambitious I think
we set ourselves the 5% and then the the
200,000 funds to add to that 5% over
that 3 years and then we're getting a
really good return on that investment of
$200,000 in terms of a carbon
efficiency so this is an area of
expertise that I have none of so uh you
two can help me out because in
recommendation six there it talks about
provide guidance as to whether the
council seeks a more ambitious Net Zero
Target
then 2050 so that could be 2040 if you
say Tom um noting that the forecast
roughly half a million to 1.6 million
annual operation operational expenditure
required to offset emissions is
dependent on offsetting
approach that that's not quite right um
is it ran because it's that is if we did
nothing we respect to reducing our
absolute emissions that's if you have to
if you have to plant so that you're
achieving Zero by planting or by buying
credits whereas what we what we a to do
the reason whole point $100,000 is to
try to reduce the gross emissions displ
it yeah so that you so the number would
be you know I mean if it was 50% it'd be
50% of those numbers yeah um yeah so
you're correct um Deputy Mayor that
that's those figures are provided for
comparison based on if we were not to
reduce our emissions at all from this
point and they were to be stud what it
would cost to offset those every year so
it's a comparison item I do think it's
important to note what's contained
within the report that essentially we
have picked the loow hanging fruit so
just to councel der's point um and as
council's actually done quite a lot
without any budget at all um to reduce
emissions and that we have done the easy
things so it's just it is important to
be aware of that okay so so therefore
the 200,000 would affect bring effect to
the 5% saving over 3 years correct
correct okay Leslie did you have a yes
that's what I was going to say the
200,000 would effectively help us to
move faster y thereby as Tom has said
justifying saying 2040 rather than 2050
yep ringy 200 the 200,000 would be a a
big contribution to us being able to
Sure move FAS
and we have the the list is the a couple
of pages and the some of the activities
we've already done like converting the
SP Splash Palace Bo boiler and the
conversion of our Fleet 34% of it
already converted um Parks maintenance
going electric wherever possible and so
forth so the examples of low hanging
fruit are there on page 97 and as Real's
indicating we we've pretty much picked
the low hanging fruit y not going to S I
know but just to calibrate the you know
we we have emissions of 95,000
tons that compares with southland's
total emissions of 65 million right T
Ty's get
600,000 so ear 9,000 you know as a drop
in the ocean I don't mean that in a
sense it doesn't matter I mean it in the
sense that it's not that difficult
actually you know if if we're expecting
a whole economy net Zer by 2015 then ear
95,000 really we should be able to make
that disappear long before then that's
why I'm suggesting 2040 okay and the
200,000 as a contestable fund would
allow staff to generate some
Innovative projects and one's already
been referred to but there could be
others that would assist us with that
okay ringy no oh sorry um uh does
council have to be we wey or take notice
of its contractors if they have a uh
carbon profile do we does that affect us
who who we use um or is it it doesn't
really matter both either in providing
uh services like roading whatever even
to the point of where we invest uh spare
cash which we do you know look at our
investments do we take note
of does that bank or financial
organization have links to you know
whatever so are we weary of that or we
don't really care so if we get a
contractor R it's fine or is that
something this policy should cover Ranna
or Michael so I can speak briefly to
that um you may recall when we put in
place the procurement policy that we
started to we looked at that um the
issue of carbon at that point we've
started to collect some information from
contractors um that F fits within that
broader scope it's not recommended to go
there at this point um that's based on
advice from the ministry for environment
and others um there isn't yet guidance
for how local government should be
working across this area so um we you
know as the report does say we're
expecting that we will be required to do
this going forward so we're very much in
uh Gathering more information learning
and starting as um Tom says with the
areas that we can address directly
ourselves so does that include financial
institutions that we may deposit our
money
with that would be I can't answer that
question
F you just um in regard to the
contestable fund is part of the idea
that any um Innovative and creative
initiative should actually spread wider
than just our Council so in terms of our
influence within um communities because
I think in some ways it follows on from
what I was saying our counciler was
saying if we um take these initiatives
seriously eventually they Ripple out
into other parts of our business
practice um so if we as a council or
somebody within our Council comes up
with a really good
um project that reduces um
emissions we can uh let the public know
if it's applicable to other
organizations is that sort of part of
the thinking behind all of this not just
that it helps us do better but it could
help the community do
better like to comment on that
RNA um so I'm sure there would be
learning that could be shared um I would
anticipate that the fund in the first
instance would focus on those areas
where our Target is specifically Focus
which is on reducing council's emissions
first
um and but I would imagine that after
time if it was proving to be a
successful approach it could certainly
be broadened
out thank
you um oh sorry ly oh that's okay I was
just going to say it's it's phrased as a
contestable fund for Council projects to
reduce emissions but as Ron's
indicating depending on the innovations
that put forward for the contestable
fund there could very well be flow on
effects or other ways and which that
those particular project principles
could be used to widen the the
impact I mean I think one sorry through
you chair the the um although we are
focused on our own emissions you know
get your own house in order first right
but but Council will have a leadership
accountability with respect to you know
the broader Community now we don't we
don't have any legal accountability in
that with that respect at the moment but
it it might well be that at some point
the future that is given to us so where
we do where we do leadership
accountability is adaptation now nobody
else is going to do that that's going to
be a call who's who's going to stop you
know flooding well if we don't do it
nobody else is going to do job
yep any other discussions no so for your
benefit and I will put uh
recommendations
um 1 through n without five 7even and
eight which requires an agree or a
disagree and we'll do them
separately uh and just for your benefit
to note the comments that have been made
around U recommendation six about um
going a bit faster if we want a better
words um that we have some um appetite
for
that I'll second that if you're move
okay yeah I'll move those there second
so this is this is excluding 5 seven
and8 all those in favor I carried and
now with options five 7 and8 we'll do
them separately so that people can have
some discussion five is we agree or
disagree um to an internal contestable
fund I'll move that we agree to
that gr the community is what you're
moving sorry you what you would be
moving was that you would be agreeing to
consult the
community the agreement or disagreement
oh sorry yes sorry yeah yeah so I'll
I'll put that we agree Grant second of
that all those in favor I any opposition
no thank you in in
seven um we've got um an agree and
disagree situation there somebody like
to move one
way leave it to me we agree we agree
second for that
second yeah all those in favor of
agree any
opposition there being none and the
final one is
option8 and I will personally put um
disagree with that allocation to
enironment sou and Grant seconding there
on the
assumption that uh I don't think we
should be um contributing to more data
analysis by environment sou and I think
they've had long enough jimy I speak to
that before you certainly and R you to
follow yeah sorry um so we we've got
lead our data new for pretty much the
whole of Southland southland's a big
place Y and there will be an enormous
amount of data analysis done which is
useless unless you include it include in
it things like flow rates of the river
and so forth it's not just a matter of
you know Finding exactly higher um
something is you got to also figure out
how much the the flow rate of the river
is going to change so it's an an
enormous task so even even although
region even although if um environment
South were here they probably can in no
that it's probably their broader
accountability the problem is that they
might get to the W hoai in you know 2090
or something right so if if we if we
want to get to if we want to get that
data analysis done for critical parts of
your system it may be that we're going
to have to fund some of that ourselves
correct just practically it just cannot
be done
by yeah for I kind of ringing I guess my
reflection of that is that
um that would be fine so long as if we
were contributing we get
priority and I'm not sure that he who PE
calls the
shots I'll let Mike will contribute to
that shortly Ry uh no look it's their
job that this is what we this what we
pay our environment settl rights for
sorry
yeah was is there anybody else oh hold
on
Darren oh if it were a perfect world
we're a small land mass and they're
massive catchment and I think if we want
to get priority uh we're going to have
to pay for it otherwise you'll be
waiting because there's a whole lot of
uh rural constituencies they're going to
be asking for the same
thing despite the fact that we are a
significant part of the population they
will look at things from a land mess
perspective and I guess my my previous
reflection it has been that while that's
very true that's not to say that they
that environment s won't take the land
mass approach regardless of whether we
give only only 5,000 or not reward based
Council others who wish to
have um yes I think for my perspective
umwa that it's actually important that
we invest on behalf of our area
to get the information that we
specifically need to manage our area so
an example of that would
be um the information that we needed to
inform the Sandy Point management plan
and going specifically and requesting
and Contracting for that I think that we
perhaps need to look not at us
offsetting the cost of ear doing work
that they would be doing anyway but
looking at Contracting to obtain
information that we need to inform our
decision making
specifically what is within our
particular business area
so contrary I I see it as an investment
in managing our assets okay before a go
to others I guess if uh environment
South is also being asked for funding
maybe they're asked for 150 given their
land mass will we be collect ly funding
work that should be done by years that's
right I think though Che that I mean you
may add to that if you wish you know
that that money Contin stays under our
control it's not a $75,000 gift to
environment Southland it is sponsoring
particular piece of work that we ask for
okay and if that's the cas that is that
is correct it's not to be passed to
environment South and it's for putting
against a specific project when that
information becomes available
okay rangy look under our procurement
process we can't just give them as R and
said 75 grand we would have to have an
would have to know what we were going to
get we I mean you can't just partner and
say Here's 75 grand as number eight says
sorry it's we can't should I try to get
five grand for the CCTV project and
that's that's you know taken a while so
$5 grand um uh no unless we know what
we're going to get so I I can't see
under our procurement how we can just
approve
that uh Lely thanks Mr May I'm going to
speak in support of what um councelor
CBO and councilor llo and Reverend cook
have already said um he who pays the
piper calls the tune this is asking us
to allocate
75,000 towards further data analysis
that we would be asking environment
Southland to do on the particular areas
that we saw as important for our own
Council
critical um
risk we would be specifically asking
environment Southland to do work on a
project that we had specified to me it
is a reasonable amount of money for us
to set aside for a very important thing
for this Council to do the raw data is
important yes but we know that that raw
data needs further data analysis for
core risks this Council faces whether
that's the airport or one of our River
catchments we will need to ask
environment self introduc some specific
further analysis on the data on areas
important to us
and we do not want to be an acue that
puts that in the far distant time when
for a small amount of money set aside
now we can have the assurance that we
have the ability to ask that further
data as we identify what is critical to
us so I'll put the motion shortly one
way other that will clarify this from my
own personal
perspective um and I think about a
parallel process if I wanted a health
and safety assessment done by work uh
work saf New
Zealand um I would expect it to be done
uh whether I'd expected to be done ahead
of anybody else and whether I had an
ability to pay the agency to do my
assessment quicker than somebody else's
I don't think that's right I don't think
it's ethically right um uh we Face
ongoing costs all the time this
organization does and uh I pay my
regional rates and I expect them to do
the job and if they don't have enough
staff to analyze the data they need to
fund that just as we do as well we don't
tend to go to uh other organizations and
say for agum sake look we'll only
process your consent if you give us some
sort of um support financially to do
that um so but I'm happy to for somebody
to put the agree if they want to
um table so M sorry sorry mine's on the
table it may be that you I mean it we
we're talking about data analysis yeah
to help us make decisions like you know
infrastructure and so forth the words
with in partnership with environment
southlander there it does not have to be
spent with them y it could be spent with
Consultants quite separately from
environment Southland and and you know
and I think if it's that part that
concerns you because environment souland
will not do everything I mean they all
just not they don't have the money they
don't have the people um they see places
like matara and goras higher risk than
we are so we're going to be a long way
down the track it might be that if we
want some work done and I think we will
some work done more quickly it's not
necessarily the money is going to be
spent is going to be analyzed by
environment Southland it could be one of
the private agencies that this work this
work is that right ran and and therefore
I would propose you just take out the
words in partnership with bment South
and just allow
$75,000 for data analysis to assist
climate change risk to the
city yeah that that's correct and if
that assists remove that wording gives
us the flexibility to spend it where
it's going to have best impact great
yeah so I um disagree with that
fundamentally because I think it's
double dipping and I think it abdicates
environment sou from the guardianship
they have to take for all communities in
their catchment they rate US
significantly and if they this work
which they've undertaken because of the
benefit of that work to those
communities they should have made that
decision that they were going to put
that information out as quickly as
possible if they haven't and they need
additional funds to get that information
out then they've made the mistake in my
view so I don't see why we need to
additionally fund more money from to
environment Southland to get information
that they've collected for the benefit
of everyone in their community so that's
why I oppose it however what Tom's put
forward if if if this is worded
differently around because I do see the
benefit in the light our data and US
using it effectively I'm not opposed to
that it's just the double dipping
approach to an additional take from the
already rates that we pay as a city and
their rate pay is pay that's what I'm
opposed to so would you be happy for
those words to be taken
out yeah I would too but having said
that that leaves the discretion with the
chief executive about where the 75,000
spent and I would want some comfort zone
that that didn't go back
to funding something in environment Heth
and if they've got extra needs for
analysts for want of a better work and
they don't have them they should procure
them just as we do from time to time and
they rate accordingly so to to that
point would we not write to environment
health and and get um an undertaking of
how they propose to provide that
information to us when and all those
sorts of things so then we can see is it
worth employing it or if they simply say
we're not giving the information till
you pay the money that'll be an
interesting response I don't think they
would say that but then we can ascertain
okay well then we'll invest the 75,000
on the basis of we're going to get this
information here and we can then invest
in it and get the best for City out of
it and the best bank for a back right
P I'll go to Darren first thank you I
wonder if then if we're deleting
environment south from from there if we
add to assess the climate change risk to
our core Council assets so we're more
defining what it is that the money's for
ACC assets yeah yeah I'm okay with
that I'll come back to you in a minute
Ry uh thank you through yourself M um I
think you started to get to the key
point just at the end there which it's
it's actually about the use of two data
here and we're kind of missing the point
that we own the data that we in relation
to the core assets and we need the light
R data that they they've got in relation
to that and then we need to model it on
our own core assets um and that's where
the climate risk to our own core assets
comes into it and that's what the money
is about is in relation to us modeling
our data um so that's not environment
Southland modeling the LI data it's
using that data to model it against our
own data that we have on our own assets
um and that's where that that difference
is it's not um and working the part
around working in Partnership was is
mainly around using their data to come
across and actually where we need to
interpret it um working with them so we
can understand it better From
perspective our own core assets actually
all of the data is Public
Access not necessarily from our own core
data no no I'm saying that you know the
invironment so data as public
access okay
Ry look to me it's it just appears from
all the discussion that environment
South doing their job and we're relying
on another option or I mean it's like us
going out to someone else because we're
not happy uh with the performance I mean
this is a key role whether it be you
know southland's a large area
but it it is really important that we
understand those risks but we we also
have to acknowledge that environment
Southland is really of no use and and
and US progressing
this we just basically cannot do
it you know all of the possible flood
points in the whole of
Southland no matter how Keen they are
even no matter how much money they have
they just kind of do it all themselves
once thank you uh Mr
so with the suggestions that have been
made we would be changing the
recommendation to say that Council agree
to allocate 75,000 towards further data
analysis the further data analysis is
the key here we have or we will have the
raw data from environment Southland it
is the further data
analysis that is the important key here
towards further data analysis to assess
climate change risk to core inago city
council assets necessary to maintenance
of
life that's the key the key is the
further data the further data
analysis there is no argument that
environment sou will provide us what we
expect them to as the raw data and the
liar data it is is the further data
analysis that we will need need to those
core assets of importance to in Bago
city
council that's what we're setting aside
the
$75,000 for and that is why I believe
that is a reasonable and in fact
slightly improved recommendation to
clarify sure that that is what we're
zeroing in on it's the further data
analysis and it's importance to us at
the speed that this counil so SE is as
important okay thank you Alan um I I
agree with rangy I believe that every uh
every in City already pays environment
settlement rates for information from
environment sett this is a job that they
should be doing for us it's part it's
what they're it's what they do and I
also just said as another thing like
it's just another 75,000 where above we
going to go get consult on another
200,000 and it just every time we come
to meetings you know that you're always
there's a 75,000 here and 100,000 here
and 200,000 and we're short of money I
mean times these these times are tight
and this is a very very very long-term
um problem so do we need to be ourselves
putting any any more money towards us I
think little self and do do their job
and they've got years to do it it's not
doesn't have to be done overnight or
next year or the year after so I'm uh I
disagree
okay so I'll put that amended uh motion
which
Michael agree yes we agreed to that
Amendment um I I'm still opposed anyway
um I just think we should have some
accountability on environment sou to do
their job um we don't use that excuse
with other so I'll be voting in support
of the disagreement but I'm I'm happy to
put that and grants put it um so as you
vote you'll be voting for The disagree
portion of that 75,000 those who are in
favor can sit silent to start with um so
I'll do a show hand so that we know
who's voting not necessar who's voting
Which Way But just to make sure we get
the numbers right so that's saying it's
agree at the moment oh sorry should
be you you moved I've mov you moved to
disagree I've moved to disagree you've
had a second Grant seconded okay yep so
I'll put that disagreement and for those
that support that we don't uh provide at
this stage 75,000 although we could at
some later stage look at the further
data but I think the first step should
be the accountability on environment sou
um if you can just raise your hands I
can get an idea of the feel what are we
voting for voting to voting to disagree
that we so that in effect they're saying
that we're not we're not going to put
aside 75,000 for further
analysis yeah so one one two three four
five five
six and those who are opposed to that
motion I.E that they want the 75 put
aside one no Mal can't vote one 2 3 4 5
uh motion is carried for the
disagreement good
luck got
that excellent thank you for your
patience on that you're going need it
okay3 long-term draft budget Direction
which is tab
13 series of recommendations here and
Rihanna this is yours
again so thank you mayor so this is
really council's opportunity just to
give direction on these items um in
terms of enabling the finance team to
pull together the draft long-term plan
budgets and the infrastructure team to
pull together the asset management plans
it's just important to be aware
obviously all of these decisions remain
um um in play Until the Whole ltp is
landed um but this would um form the
Budget prior to audit and consultation I
just want to draw your attention to a
few specific items where there have been
some changes just to alert you to those
um so the first of that is
under FF which is the road map to
Renewal
projects
um point three we're recommending
bringing CCTV into the road map and
allocating that further funding to do
that part of the
project so just noting there um and then
also under
f.5 the bluff boat ramp and um apologies
this was an error during the earlier
discussions on this um the items that
the bluff community board had asked for
in terms of um adding to the scope of
that produte which is for additional
toilets is added and
operational expenditure that operational
expenditure is a oneoff expenditure to
scope for the car pack um so just
drawing your attention to those two
items
specifically yeah thank you for that so
I'll I'll start the discussion off by
just working through the list um I guess
my reflection is
that um often when we've had these sort
of workshops on the last one was a good
example of that um I personally WR some
reservations about some issues and
people heard that but then it just seems
to plot on quite nicely with the figures
so I'll raise them again given that
we're in a decisionmaking area now on 2
aanan it talks about wakah road to zero
low cost and low risk safety
improvements $2.4 million and I raised
at the workshop and so I'll raise it
again I don't know why we are committing
$2.4 million of capital uh starting next
year given that the the definition by
nature is low
risk and not only that heading towards a
um a road to zero focus at 2050 I think
um which I don't think anybody in this
world believes it will ever ever get to
that so that's one issue for me um the
other issue I raise which is on
2D which a City Center maintenance and
repair cost and I was um supportive of
having somebody do that it just seems
100,000 is an awful lot of money perom I
know there'll be some initial equipment
to buy but I mean if I was thinking
about this the center city you'd
probably only have a part-time worker
there I'm not sure um how we get to that
100,000
um the
outar
um
um rubbish collection um
um is is currently quite a capital and
an operational cost to us going forward
um and and I wonder again given that uh
everybody notara makes their own
arrangements for uh rubbish collections
um the cost to the rate payer is going
to go up because um I know what it cost
me to have the weekly bin um the
recycling bin
um and and I guess the um
the final issue in that is the is the
one the new pump track which is u in
South in Vago I raised the fact that the
kex cost for that was4 million where the
odara one was 120 was the cost to Parks
I don't believe what we put into South
City will be twice the size in fact I
think it they'll be struggling to have L
sizewise bigger than the one that's
ataro given the the land that's
available um by Russell Square on the
north side of Russell Square um so I
guess they're the issues that I
raise the other the other issue um I
guess just as a comment for you rean is
in 3 A and
B um which are the extensions of water
and surage into
odara I've raised this with the incoming
national government um that I don't see
why um the previous government
desired to have everybody in a city on
on water and/
seage um would apply to odara given the
semi- Ral and that you don't have to go
very far out of odara to find Farmers
that will not be impacted by this
because the cost to the rate pay the
individual rate pay is significant so I
asked a question at the workshop um over
and above being rated for this so by the
time this impacts at 2036 the current
water rate which is currently about 800
will probably be
1,800 and so by that time to suddenly
have a bill that goes up by that amount
and one go um and
um um where that water system has been
in place Forever at odara and I'm not
aware of anybody getting sick from
collecting water off their roof as they
don't in the rural areas um so I've
asked the central government whether
they will look at that and I've got an
undertaking back from some key players
of national say as part of the three
Waters look they will look at that
wording around does everybody in the
city now odara is quite unique and its
uniqueness is it it's semi- rural but
it's very very close to the city
normally these places are a bit further
out um but they said they will look at
that provision around that so just I
guess I'm just signaling
that Ry um is there someone who can
answer questions on the wah thing sure
is that is would you like to comment on
the two or three issues that I raised
which is walk K and the maintenance of
the central city so we the figures
quoted there are they the total figures
and is the fund assistant rate applied
to that or is that our particular cost
because obviously um with the work we do
with wqah it's it's all contested and so
when it says 2.4 million is it actually
4.8 or what is it is it we putting in
half of
that so um the first point I would make
m is that all of these decisions in this
paper are brought to you as a council to
make um we have clustered them as
indicated earlier to make the decision
process easier I don't think anyone
would have wanted to see agree disagree
against every item but just to make that
clear um on the question of the Waka
kahi funding the first item 2A is
co-funded so what's our share is that
that our share our share is is the fire
rate at
49% and so is b c is not C is 100%
funded by us okay so that 2.4 is
actually 1.2 yes right if I jump in here
and these are the gross
for fund before contribution
amounts we've got to have the expense in
to we have to have the expense in our
budgets yeah to get and then we put a
matching far as another budget line it
just reads different when you read it
that way it's a longterm plan as we
explained in the workshop through the
longterm plan we put in the cost and
then also have a different line with the
um subsidy
income yes okay uh r and just a
reflection on your an opening comment
there that uh councilors would not want
to uh get an agree or disagree as we go
through the list that's certainly not my
perspective of next time we do this I
would expect that to actually happen
that you'd get a feel from the room on
each single item that you're doing it's
frustrating from my end and it will be
from other people's ends to raise
concerns and then uh not getting a feel
for how the room feels about it and then
to have it come up in a in a final
report cuz if we're going to do that
then why do we have the
workshop so so that's a reflection going
forward I
guess May sorry maybe I'm just wasn't
clear enough when I spoke I meant purely
how I had written the report sure um
they certainly we did take into account
the feedback around the council table um
that's why the paper was brought back on
the second day of the workshop um and no
further changes were provided which is
why they're provided the way they are
what I'm trying to say is this paper for
discussion now is the opportunity if you
feel that we have got any of that wrong
in terms of where it ought to be to have
that discussion and to move items around
okay okay so from my perspective the the
two that are
wrong um in particular are
um uh 2 a and
2D
so can I inquire what you then want to
do with those are you suggesting well I
guess I guess what I in the paper or
well again this is this is the this is
the the floor in the system for me as I
did raise this at the workshop um and
and while um we may have $100,000 cost
in the first year to set up equipment
for whoever's going to do the inner city
um maintenance on a daily basis or
whatever it turns out to be which I
agree with because we need to maintain
what we've put together um once you've
got the equipment available I wouldn't
have thought $100,000 was an appropriate
cost of what is probably 20 hours wor of
work a week um if you think where our
inner city is which is I guess Walk
Place uh es and Dawn Street and the
connecting streets that's not a 40h hour
a week job 80 hours a day I wouldn't
have thought yes so M what I'm asking is
for that one for instance y are you
suggesting it stays in this list with an
amended figure yep potentially but again
it would have been I guess and I'm I'm
not trying to reinvent the wheel here
but I think as we go forward having this
discussion back in the work shop stage
would be helpful so that we're not going
through line by line on this one because
that will be a painful exercise
but anyway yeah I I I will I will move
on amendment to that because the issue
is it does say
perim so it's an ongoing cost it's not
just a oneoff cost to start with so then
can I ask on 2A y were you suggesting an
amendment to that or removing that to
the list and well personally for me I'd
remove because I I think that any uh any
safety Improvement that by definition is
low risk that we've got other properties
and even if our Shar is $1.2 million
that's uh close to a 2% rate
increase and again per anom you're
suggesting then moving that particular
one to item four which says agree the
foll following items will not be
included sorry yeah recommendation four
in this list yep is one that says agree
the following items will not be included
in the draft budget and may be reviewed
are you suggesting 2 a should be removed
to be for correct um T but I'm open to
people having some discussion about that
I saw I saw Patricia frowning there
before and I suggested it's a 2%
increase through Vice we were given at
this Workshop is roughly every 700,000
in cost is about 1% in the rate increase
so that if we have our share of that
Walker kah being roughly half that
amount 1.2 million per year
that's 1.6 1.7 1.8% rate increase just
to correct you there may Clark at
700,000 of operational cost this is 2.4
million of capital perom and that if I
recall um from the workshop was what um
Russell said was our our intersection
improvements our dangerous intersections
or the those ones it's the improvements
on a road the low cost low risk category
is a Waka kotahi category um and that's
how they categorize different um
projects we currently have at I'm trying
to think back in the I would say it be
about the same amount if not a little
bit less in there at the moment so we
wanting to maintain that if not more but
that's subject to the Waka katah yeah
claim anyway so we have to put a budget
through Daka kah but around Christmas
time with what we'd like to do so it's
still subject to their approval
I'll come back to the hands up in a
minute just as a reflection of that I
can't reconcile how you you make the
statement that we have potentially High
danger intersections which I think are
the words you use against a Waka kahi uh
lowrisk safety Improvement suggestion
that we contribute 1.1 or $1.2 million
to it may have been a poor choice of
words it was intersection intersection
improvements
y okay I've got some hands
up Grant yeah so a couple of things and
that points discussions probably
highlighted it so it the purpose of
doing this is to get it in the long-term
plan to sort of project what our
proposed expenditure is we still have
the opportunity to come back at each
annual cut of our budget to say that's
in or out right sure so that's important
to remember I believe second point to
what Patricia talked about and I agree
with how she's explained it the
discussion at the workshop was very much
about this money is set aside to improve
some highrisk intersections likes of mil
Road um North and um Banfield Road as an
example which has had a couple of very
well few very close calls so that's a
good example and having it in bookmarked
only gives us the opportunity to bid for
the money for wer if we don't have it a
long-term plan we can't ask for it yeah
and it's always scaled so it's a it's a
sort of a flagging to w k we're going to
invest this money in our long-term plan
over these years Y and then we'll bid
and we still get the opportunity through
each year to say whether we would put
the money in that particular year I do
believe we have oh M's just nodding he
knows what pay slightly better than I do
we
don't uh through yourself um Che there's
a number of things I probably need to
cover in relation to this particular
topic would draw your attention back to
the workshop it was exactly what um
councelor um deoy was just saying in
relation to matching what the bid was in
relation to what go but also what's in
your infrastructure strategy plan in
relation to
roading um you have a three-year
commitment in relation to what when you
sign off so um you lock it in basically
for three years you can place a little
bit within the categories um but that's
in discussion with what goah and I just
want to highlight categories in relation
to the low risk safety Improvement
aspect that's highlighted that's looked
at and deemed from a national scale so
your roads of significance come into the
category of high risk um side of it they
they then turn to look at the local
roads um into a different categorization
so you start to see why they put certain
things in different areas what we deem
might be high RIS from a local
perspective um may not necessarily be
from a National perspective we won't
have the same traffic going through it
Etc but we may want to do that
Improvement and putting it Forward into
that so that's why the categories are
slightly different to what we would
recognize if we looked at it at a local
lens um hopefully it highlights it the
reason it matches um those figures and
came through from the workshop was was
because we did discuss that item in the
workshop in relation to matching our bid
to
Wah in line with our asset management
plan knowing that we the uplift we're
potentially going to get is not a um
close to this we don't expect that we
will get this uplift but we noted that
we will adjust in relation to what's bid
and that's what we'll end up coming
through we need to demonstrate that we
could afford it if we if full bid yeah
so so another way of framing this if I
may respond me is you know this is
actually us bidding to get subsidization
to make some of their key intersections
and other areas safe sure so by not
having it in we don't get the
opportunity to subsidize nationally and
we miss out on a lot from a national
perspective so I think we've got to have
it in my view so the flip side of that
is that we put it in the long-term plan
and we don't get the subsidy are we then
committed by a longterm plan to
resolving the issues no we're not
okay that's all good bring um look I
understand now I mean we've had all this
discussion about what A and B are for
but if you're the public looking at our
agenda and reading this you'll all you
see is 2.4 million 2.5 million and you
have no idea what it what it's for we've
just heard that it's for dangerous
intersections and stuff sorry as chair
of infrastructure I would like to
actually see a bit more detail because
we must have had that detail to come up
with these numbers so like even the one
down below it that says about uh Road
Safety actually says outside schools at
least you can relate to that there is
nothing in Al that gives you a
clue what the money's for seriously I
think there needs to be more detail we
just can't adopt something like that
without without some detail and
examples yeah to I mean to we're
probably privileged that we've had the
opportunity to workshop with us but to
ringy's point we probably haven't
reflected that through public minutes oh
sorry agas so that's yeah
so uh
Rihanna um I'll just draw your attention
to page 149 of board books for example
that gives more information in the body
of the report um on that specific item
um there is a basic level of information
about each item in this report but the
report also notes that the full
information will come through in the
asset plans um next month this is one
step of a process to enable the
finishing of those
plans okay thank
you okay anybody else like to contribute
to the the list
Evelyn just a clarification through you
to renon
um two
double oh sorry i' moved off it
um two D I think it is it's the um
discussion of the operational costs of
to AATA
facility um is this setting it out as a
separate line item instead of being
included in other budgets because I mean
once upon a time it would have been in
the museum
budget I imagine currently it just sits
as a an item within Park budget is this
actually showing the actual cost of
Staffing and um security electricity
whatever for the new
facility so you want me to speak to that
may sure so
um yes you're absolutely correct these
items will all become part of the
relevant activity budgets these this one
is in there because the facilit the
facility is new and therefore there's a
new line item needed for operating the
facility um if the facility had already
existed then it would be within the
standard
core on ongoing operational
cost so it's a reflective of a more
precise way of accounting for an
activity that once upon a time just was
hidden within a bigger within a bigger
picture yes I think the answer would be
yes and that and this is what we've
brought through with all the new
facilities says you'll note some Tisbury
lines as well um this is us reflecting
in the budgets that this is additional
on top of existing
operational K thank you for
that any other
questions this is way too
easy
oh thank you deuty may of
aara hardly I'm just looking through the
other things I just notic the bus
service aara yes and I mean if I was to
read that I'd think that you're going to
spend
$150,000 on operational expenditure per
do you do you want to cor the section
you're referring to it's on page 155
okay not actually one of the points over
the over the other way though I noticed
but it's in the it's in the back part
there I think you find but if you read
that if somebody us to read these notes
and they read that there it would read
to me that they're going to spend
$150,000 a year on a bus service start t
y just the way it reads on in the in the
notes it's not one of the things on
page5 sorry councilor I didn't mean to
cut you off
um so the the body of the report
includes every item under the activity
area the resolutions include whether you
want that item in in the infrastructure
strategy or out that is one of the items
that is on your list that you do not
want within the
plan so that's just to
clarify it is in within it is within the
resolutions think just looking at the
resolutions it's sitting is number
something it's Q is the it's it's 4
q 4 q 4 q right four four is the ones
that
[Laughter]
are very
unfortunate sorry the school boy just
came
yes it's also with a new
Street
sitting I just want to make comment
around the um extension of water and
sewage to otara and I know that today we
were talking about people sitting in the
past and we're trying to look into the
future and I suppose for this I think
it's important that we look into the
future for you know
the or you know and how that connects
with the city in time yep just as a
reflection that I live in h Tower
obviously and I get quite a bit of
feedback on this issue and most most
people are saying if we've got a a
system where we have tanks and some have
three
tanks um I've only got one um and we
have the access to the city water supply
by way of tanker if we get short why do
we then get a cost to hook up to a
central system where the existing system
works okay because it's not it's not a
freebie there is cost to rates and in
some cases cost to extension cuz quite a
few of those Bush sections go back into
the bush so mine goes about 200 M no 150
M if I connect the seid through the bush
I've got a $40,000 Bill if I go down the
the road itself it's going to be cheaper
of course but um so that's I guess the
questions that I that are put to me um
why do you change your system is it just
a a decision that all all cities will
have everybody connected up regardless
of where they fit um give being mindful
that rd9 is not Rd which is odara is
wider than Oda so there'll be some
people out at the beach I suspect and
some people going out stting Road and
things that will not be on the system
because they won't be deemed to be part
of the city but they're out further out
so any
otherone um just in terms of expansion
of services to
Alla this is long-term plan so therefore
there must become a point at which
people who go are actually going more
into a
Suburban areas rather than more rural
isolated lifestyle however you want to
phrase that so the sections getting
smaller people being more closely um
situated therefore the demand for
services May tip the other way is this
up future proofing that we are
constantly looking and exploring the
possibilities of extending services to
places that don't currently get services
and that is making keeping us as a
council future proofing um so it's not
just this the water but it could be any
of the things that are particularly
directed towards utata um rather than
just saying oh we you know lots of
people will have these already but if
you're a new person going into a smaller
subdivision do you necessarily want to
have that expense or are we starting to
see an expectation that there will be
reticulated water or the the options for
sege on a section become less practical
where it has to be offsite um surge
disposal I'm posing the question because
I know that as we um are
intensify these will be questions that
people are asking are we approaching
that Tipping Point therefore we're doing
this planning okay I can answer that
because I've had some discussion with
Russell and and others around this exact
issue so the issue I guess the wider
issue is this is not a a city uh suburb
because if you go to odara with the
exception of three streets that were
Allen and two adjoining streets that
were a social experiment everywhere in
oara you have one or two options on the
sides of your section so in my case I'm
not connected to the sewage I have to be
at least a hectare so that's 2 and half
acres I cannot subdivide lower than that
if I'm connected to the sege and many of
them are currently connected to the sege
one acre is the minimum size of section
so even even if we have a subdivision at
the current rate you can't have a
subdivision that has 40 sections on it
that are all an eighth of an acre that's
not possible in out so what they're
saying is they've gone out there for a
lifestyle Choice they've taken the extra
cost of the land cuz there is an extra
cost of course having big sections um
and they don't see the reason for the
extension to a city type approach when
it's it's clearly semi um semi- rural
the other issues are quite a few of the
sections and there are about a thousand
in odara rd9 is actually 1500 but um in
the OU tower part there'll be fect about
a thousand sections um a big major of
those are now on the SE system um we got
quite a large drawn map that Russell
uses where you can join up as you go
there but some can't so some of the
subdivisions are falling outside that
but the water's different cuz nobody's
got
water so that's quite a significant cost
Tom I I was just going to observe that I
think that what we've done actually
reflects what Evelyn said anyway we
haven't actually taken out we we've just
said it's outside of 10
you know the 10 year ltp so I think
leaving it in there outside reflects
exactly what you're saying everyone
there may come a there yeah yeah and
what I was saying to that Tom when I
initially raised it was not to say that
it shouldn't happen what I was
suggesting was that the government has
signal that they want that to happen
that all City dwellers for one of the
better was have access to sewage and to
three Waters um and and the current
government may look to back away from
that little bit to allow for the odar
type
situations
so further questions um i' I've got
um an amendment to put on the
um where the hell was
I 2D 2D uh
2D um I think that's too high so I'll
take some advice on that but I don't
want to argue over 30 or 40,000 and a
200 million business um and the other
one was the uh the potential for the
uh the pump track down in South
City which is
you um I think 250 is way too high I
think 150 is any amount enough to get
that in
there so I'll I'll I would like to move
Amendment on that on that 250 um if
people are happy with that then I'll
move it if not I'll isolate that out and
and V on that one
separately quick feel on the
room so
sorry what are you moving so on on the
issue of uh you issue you which is a new
pump
track I change it to 150 not 250 it's
too
expensive um and so the ru of the G the
room is Keen for that um then I can make
that Amendment
and we just vote on the whole lot um
leaving the other stuff aside um and and
as um Patricia said while we put in
100,000 for the inner city cleaning it
might be that when we get to the next
annual plan we reduce that amount down
yeah ringy uh look just on the pump
track one obviously we had uh how many
years ago the Costello Legacy one and
theya and that was $80,000 no all up the
cost was 120 it was 120 okay so there's
a reference point is this on a Sim
similar scale yes i' I've looked at the
space that sits on it if you come across
where Russell square is you got a
playground and you come across the
street and there's an open piece of land
there then there's some trees and then
there's a two dog areas those trees
areas in there unless you want to clear
those trees out I suspect they wouldn't
want to do that um will be of comparable
size to the outar one the odar one is
reasonbly large when you get onside it
it's got quite a bit of space but highly
used and when I asked the question the
other day the the advice was what we're
looking in South City was twice a size I
just don't think you could get twice a
size on that piece of land you'd put it
way too close to the adjoining road
which would be a safety
risk
but I'm not going to die in a ditch over
there a
m t size sorry they probably need they
probably need one twice of size well
they do but you got to have the land to
put it on and it's got to be in an
environment to safe one of the issues of
the odara one even though we got an
arterior Road the kids can't get from
the pump track to the road yeah they
right intervening ditches that make that
Bloody
impossible and and when you look at the
the mobile pump track that the head down
and Bluff been around the thing I mean
it fited in a room about the so so y um
I'm no pump track expert but the kids
had fun on it they really do yeah you go
to tower on a sunny day a weekend
there's 20 or 30 kids at any time really
there there is the question of
um it's saying South and Bago there is
still the question of whether it might
be newb Street rather than they not on
their location the location is not
specific there no so newbie Street would
allow a larger and SOA pump track and
saer
is it's not specific about the location
saying I do understand that but I also
understand and we had that discussion
quite some time ago about where it' be
located certainly my view of that was
having it by the playground which is
more focused on very smaller children
where this these pump tracks tend to
engage kids four or five through 13 or
14 that age
group I think reducing it back it's a
good idea and then if look it comes back
and it needs additional Capital we can
look at that I think we keep it at that
level
test how good we go
sure any opposition to that
Amendment you've got that
Michael okay um so I'll put all the
recommendations there are four lots of
them with a whole lot of
recommendations any opposition to them
all going at once no all those in
favor oh sorry no grants already
seconded y
all those in
favor
carried thank you
Ranna mm now gets to um talk to the
amendment to the government statement
202225 and delegation
register thank you Mr Mayor this is
another round of um minor changes by the
large part to both the governance
statement and the delegations
register uh so key change really is the
creation of the new Chief exe executive
performance appraisal committee and the
uh nominations of the mayor the deputy
mayor and councilor SOA to be uh on that
committee uh the other changes are
largely just minor and procedural for
example uh New Zealand historic places
trust uh has changed its name and is now
Heritage New Zealand po Tanga and it no
longer requires
Representatives uh so it's Tiding up
some pieces like that and also making
the change to the CCTV portfolio um
putting um the mayor into that role and
in terms of the delegations register the
key change other than the performance
appraisal committee is the deletion of
the former role of the Chief Financial
Officer and the staff positions uh that
role no longer exists and it's all been
changed to the group manager of finance
and insurance which patrier is now
occupying so is ever happy to answer any
questions
Tom the only question or comment I had
was about the CEO performance appraisal
committee where in two places in this it
talks about frequency of meetings being
annually but in reality if you look at
the tasks it would be at least three
times a year yeah you going to meet to
set the objectives you going to meet to
um you know carry out an appraisal you
then go to consult with counsel and talk
again to the CEO so you've talking about
three meetings a year rather than
one noted I can make that
change and just to reinforce that um
certainly when you're dealing with top
level jobs you can't come to an an an
annual end of year result and say look
we don't think you've delivered well
enough um you've got to give an interim
set of feedback to say look we don't
think you've done well enough in this
particular year and give the chance for
to do
better so does that make it four a year
then it does so then it makes it
quarterly rather than yeah probably
should I would think quarterly would be
a good thing I get six thank
you Peter yeah yeah I just got a
question it's not uh questioning a
representative on the southern indoor
Leisure Center charitable trust yep do
we get reports back monthly
or twice quarterly or what I think it
would be it would be highly unlikely
that that trust has monthly meetings my
experience is was less frequent than
that given that the uh trust is only
really responsible for managing the um
overall funding of the organization not
the day-to-day business there all that
meets more frequently sorry the board
underneath it meets oh for sure the
governance SS us not so I don't know the
answer to that great are you suggesting
that we should have some
feedback well I would think maybe U four
times a year or three times a year I'm
not sure I just hear
nothing Well having having said that U
we have a wide range a wide Suite of of
activities in the community that most of
us sit on in one shape or another um I
don't see a lot of feedback coming from
that either other than the annual sort
of
this is what they want going forward and
then some description that goes with it
but that tends to come from the other
agencies as opposed to our
Representatives that're on the boards of
these things um okay thank you I'm happy
Mr M it helped to prepare a paper to
suggest that our appointments to
external organizations have a reporting
regime and we would add that into our uh
calendar to bring back to council at
periodic intervals
as a suggestion yeah I'm guessing that
Council saer will have a meltdown if she
has to report on every single Council
Council appointment that she's got she's
got a whole swag of them and I I'm just
mindful of the fact that it absorbs time
more time if you have to report back
um so I'm open to some suggestions
around that but not too regular I think
would be the thing because um it gets
timec consuming as it is trash
I think I I would agree with you I think
what um Leslie said recently with regard
to the Heritage where she's reporting
back on what she knew was that kind of
thing is sufficient for us because it
could be very um you know take a lot of
time in
necessary so I'm I'm picking a
suggestion that might say six monthly a
onepage
um uh email type document that people
can read if they've got an interest if
other council's got an interest uh with
a no surprises clause which I'd expect
anyway so if something really important
comes up in the work that we're doing
then you give your colleagues a head up
heads
up I mean uh that but a small amendment
to that would be that I think it might
be it could be in a rotating basis so
that um you don't get you know 20 pieces
of paper each six months it'll be more
than that every month yeah you get two
or three you know
yeah you can work on that time table and
circulate for suggestions y that'd be
helpful any other important to that yeah
Evelyn um yes so I have a question but
I'll deal with that particular thing
first I think it would be helpful if we
all got into the habit of making sure
that our external appointment things
that the minutes are routinely sent back
to council or governance team or whoever
is most relevant so therefore it's not
solely dependent on the on the member
just in case we've had members depart in
the past we all move on at some point
that there's a continuation about
information sharing so if whoever is the
Secretariat of the
organization um make sure that a copy of
minutes is forwarded that that would
cover some of that and then councilors
would be able to ask the represent of
questions um because they'd have access
to the minutes or the outcomes so my
question actually was um under
5.3.2 Community well-being um Arts
culture and Heritage including smag um I
question whether that is actually
technically correct any
longer given that smag is an independent
trust which is funded
externally I believe it no it is no long
no
longer um it's still correct and that
that's where Museum reporting uh line
leads up to but it's not as respons it's
not a CCU that the committee is
responsible for anymore um it is
something that we will have to look to
change that
wording well technically it's no longer
the museum the museum will be a separate
part so I I am raising the question
because I think we need to be mindful
that there will be two separate
reporting lines if that is the case and
not to get them confused no no thank you
I um agree we will uh work on breaking
that up to make it clearer in light of
the changes that will be coming in
relation to that so expect to see a
further change uh to the delegations
register um in
November
sorry so uh just two quick responses to
that um
I I think Michael would be really
helpful that we push along the uh the
collection trust for want of a bit words
for a name change I don't know how many
times I've asked for this but lots of
times because it is confusing to the
public that we keep referring to the
Tisbury directors as some way involved
with smag that implies the museum um the
other issue that Evelyn raises as the
minutes of the meetings now I think
we've got at least the maybe even more
outside organizations we interface with
I'm not sure there'd be too many
councils that would want to
get 30 sets of minutes every second
month um I think that would I think what
that does is it turns people off they
just don't read I think getting a
snapshot from our delegates that says
look it's been business as usual but
there's a couple of key points that you
should be aware of alert you to
something you might be interested in as
opposed to just thinking Christ not
another report but open to having some
would the resourcing to be a possible
place where incoming minutes could go
the down the downside of that I guess is
that you've got to go searching if
you've got an interest and and I guess
we want we want councilors to be
informed but we don't want them to be
informed on everything hence we've got
people spread across different
organizations gr yeah I I support that I
think you know if you get a bit of a
heads up or an overarching sort of these
are two or three things discussed and
then the minutes are always there for
Discovery if people
deep but you don't want 306 of minutes
coming through
every oh look it's a different subject
that can come later it's just regarding
regarding an issue with the delegations
register sure okay go to um chapter part
a one and it's
got um what page you I don't know it's
uh page one of 31 just got to
delegations register appendix 2 uh it
says it's got the delegations for
various elected members man of fen
Representatives CE Council officers
under the manaen representatives it
states
um with full voting rights and advisory
role on
Council and I I thought you said there's
no voting rights on Council there is no
voting rights on Council but it says
that there is it's Inc really the full
voting rights applies to the committee
no no it says on Council
sorry I might read this
wrong what page it do go on to advis P
208 a board box put yes say a Comm
missing what it says is commit and an
advisory role after the word rights you
could put in the comma would have the
effect I think that you can't put a
semicolon what a semicolon it's not a
you can't put a com after an name put a
semicolon before an end comma would be
before the end I think it just needs to
correct take a point that's fair do read
right Y and technically we're not
appointed by Council either we're
appointed by it's open to
misinterpretation Y correct thank you
for that and and Michael I I have a
similar thing on the same page which is
M reps it does say the other count other
committees so um and that's that's uh
normally the case but we've now created
a chief executive performance committee
as well and so and so that's not bit
more specificity y so just to make sure
that's not incl including the
expectations of other
committees any other discussions on that
document comments oh Michael sorry yeah
through yourself me i' just like to
suggest a um another sorry a
recommendation again um number number
six which is to approve the chief
executive to make minor amendments to
reflect the current organization
structure um my references is we've
currently got our old structure
referenced in the in the documents and
we've also got a reference to her is the
CEO as well in a couple of
places yeah okay I'm happy to move
that
do you want that showing up on the
resolutions or you happy based on what
Michael has just read out yep that's
fine thank
you okay any further
discussion all right we we've got a
suite of five plus an additional sixth
one being recommended to council um
somebody like to move those oh s
grab Alex is seconded all those in
favor
carried thank you the next one is more
of an Administration one Michael just
the proposed dates there the three
recommendations
yep don't have much to I need to add to
that yep so just a couple things from my
end um it would be helpful if we could
have some colored copies of those
available you're quite handy to cut down
and hard copy yep yes can do that I
think others would probably want that
too the other issue I just wanted to C
to make sure it's still relevant was the
issue of not not having meetings during
school holidays so what that yeah I see
Alex that was me oh sorry yeah I just
saw out the side I'm
feeling I guess was the issue of
um um whether that's still relevant to
have not have them during school
holidays because it does double up
meetings in some cases we found out just
recently where we end up with two
committee meetings on the same day
so I think that was a there's quite a
benefit there to staff with that isn't
there with a lot of staff and exact
having yeah children um it's it's an you
know it's a sort of a tip to the hat
that they have other commitments sort of
we've employed El with
children in some cases ining the
population one ex of the
time ding up a couple of times a year
yep is the m me okay just wanted to
check that that was my point I think
from the way that staff felt it valued
your interaction with their children it
was totally worth a little bit of
confusion sure that's
okay so we got three uh recommendations
here then oh sorry
Trish yeah and Darren um all those in
favor car before we oh sorry can I just
point out that that number three asks us
to indicate starting at either two or 3
p.m. are we intending to indicate
which I would just note before you make
a decision on that there is only one
occasion of a committee double up um the
way the weeks for next year that those
double UPS the only other double ups are
the risk and insurance and financing
projects and that's separated by an 8:30
start and a 3:00 start so it's not the
issue that it was this time around
January is the J is the only one two of
them yeah Darren's
M was wasn't there for you I thought
there was there was also question raised
about whether we might consider moving
as a a normal thing the meetings back to
2 p.m. to early I think that's what that
no that was this one is just
um that that is an option as well yeah
I'm not I'm not I'm not really proposing
it but that's what I read was that you
were asking the question oh it's a
question that we want that they is worth
being asked when we're setting the start
times there has been um movement to 3:00
uh when I first started at Council we
met at 4 we've moved to 3 to be 4:45
used to be 7 yes so you are we ask are
we voting on whether they start at two
no or three or either two or my
recommendation when I moved I'm damn
sure I said it was
3:00 there's always flexibility
ear
2:30 3:00 is the standard starting time
thank
you
yeah okay on to tab 16 which is local
government use young elected members Hy
2023 attendance change of
dates it's simply a change of date says
has just said uh just bringing the
report back through for um confirmation
yep okay I'm happy to second second any
discussion about that yeah great yeah
just you're too old to be young I know
unfortunately age discrimination yeah um
just point for it's always good to when
people go to those um you know confer to
get sort of a briefing or something back
just ke SS and oversights and I think
four probably captures that is that sort
of what the intent is there about your
report back around you know the so it's
an effect you know to help us be more
effective as a
council there is no recommendation for
no point four councilors must
demonstrate
sorry we it yeah that would be helpful
Alex going forward it's 245 so the event
supports elected member contributing
effectively and appropriately in their
government's role so in terms of the
government's role that Alex would be
representing us she's reporting back to
us on just yeah these were the key
pieces that came up here or these are
the sort of trends that emerged from the
conference I always think that's good
because we can all grow from one person
y yep i' would be more than happy to do
that um will we set that same standard
for everybody who um attends our gz
conference yeah it's it's an interesting
it's an interesting debate um I've
attended for what four years three and a
half years now I used to do copious
notes and copious long emails and I know
most people were not receptive to that
because it was
just too much um so I I try now just to
get
ke email sorry i f an email at to
council and my summary of thoughts of
each of the sessions IED just as a bit
of an Insight without it being sort of
one step away from verm so just the key
come things come out I think knowing
what the young elected members are
thinking is is really helpful um
recently went to a conference where they
had the deputy mayor for Nelson who
looked as he was 16 it was probably a
little bit older than that um in a very
conservative Council um it was on a
panel with some much older people and he
was Bloody bright really was his
discussion was fantastic um so knowing
that input and we've got quite a few M
now that are quite young um and we got
certainly got a transition towards
female as well so it's it's it's good to
have different diversity in that group
and to know what they're thinking so yep
that's all good and I'll when I go I'll
certainly go back to just doing key
points without trying to cover every
single topic because that just puts
people to sleep I think if you're
identifying the the bullet points we can
come back if we want yeah yeah
absolutely of course and often there's
notes that come I know with local
government all the video sessions so if
someone flagged a particular thing with
an infrastructure they could actually go
and watch the full session online yeah
so it just helps us keep up Skilling and
be across governance issues the theme
for this one is ang Moa and um
we're taking over 45 young elected
members to the birth place of Arta in
wangi so there's going to be a lot of um
we're W weaving T through the entire
Copa of the conference so there's going
to be a whole lot of learning
opportunities to um UPS School quite a
few of our um young mirors as well um
across the country so yeah yep something
that as cheer um really fills my soul to
be able to provide these kind of
opportunities sure
okay three recommendations a
mov thank you Darren and Leslie all
those in favor
carried um it's can I ask a question
about that I'm not we don't get to vote
so I'm um delighted that um Alex's
co-chair is having this opportunity but
um extending what councilor dermy said
further is um marata as well if we have
members who go to
that the opportunities and making sure
that people are offered the
opportunities to be involved at that
because that is also a growth experience
for some people um so just to emphasize
that lgnz is and Ys is not the sole
extent of what the opportunities are um
and how we deal with that going forward
and I take um Council point about
reporting back as well I think um should
person go at the council's expense it
would be expected that they would report
back yeah I think we there was some
interesting debate with local government
New Zealand and the last term about um e
attending their own group and it was
interesting they they initially started
off just by saying the only people are
qualified were e with that were elected
members but they subsequently widened
that out to include people who might sit
on um as Representatives as well so um
yeah it's been an interesting
development and think then the isue then
becomes the cost as well that can I ask
question is that also to do with
training I'm sitting here listening to
you thinking I've done that um training
course this year and I haven't reported
back to anyone because my head was not
working we'll get it we'll get a pound
of flesh out of you when you said it a
hearing Ser you're getting a
qualification
and our expectation is that you then
able to do the job but I think I think
the point it's up to us to be
responsible to everyone else if we think
there's an opportunity for others to
have an Insight or to perhaps glean some
learning from something we've
experienced or attended then we should
do that because then we all grow it's
the same reason I keep halfing on about
future for local government because you
know like there something that I'm privy
to is part of my lgz role and my
National Council role but unless you
weren't sitting in that room or you know
to those conversations you wouldn't be
aware of it so it's you know like it's
those kind of things that you get those
insights that you can bring to the table
from the perspective of things you're
involved
in okay thank you so we've got a a major
late item which is the adoption of the
annual plan and before we while she gets
to the head of the table and takes us
through this massive exercise I'm just
going to jump in and do the um the minor
late item that I signal earli on which
was the issue of the naming of the
Tisbury collection facility for one of
better words and just signal I guess
with our e reps and with um our
management as well that we are getting
very close to the opening I know there's
work being done but I don't want to face
a situation that we had last time with
the museum we've got to get ahead of
this and we' got to get some media ahead
of this as well and hopefully by the
time we get to the opening very close to
we'll be in a position to invite a
minister for Heritage and culture or
somebody appropriate to come down and do
the opening as well so just being
mindful that we've only got six weeks
left for the issue of of the name and um
just to be mindful that while some may
say that well we can just call it the
tisb collection center we did make a
commitment at the time of
the paper that I put up uh when we had
eie come forward uh last time around the
museum which was um testing I guess at
one stage we did make a decision at that
meeting that we will go to bilingual
names um so while it it might be seen as
an insignificant building or
insignificant part of the museum we have
made that commitment to bilingual namage
so from my perspective it's not an
option that we can just say we'll just
have an English name or just have an e
name it's got to be both so just
flagging for the players that are
involved already involved we need a
little bit of haste on this if we
can so that we can get ahead of in
relation to the coms and get ahead with
the invites from an appropriate minister
to do it because this is the ideal
chance to engage with the new Minister
whatever shape that takes given that we
might want some funding for our Museum
shortly get them down give them a good
photo
opportunity whatever it
takes Patricia
you say that was such um this um and
apologies for this being such a major
late item but uh literally I received
sign off of the accounts from audit New
Zealand at 9: just after 9:00 this
morning um we were still making changes
yesterday um as a result of the reviews
over the weekend so um it has been an
audit right through to the wire as there
are many count um C around the country
doing the same thing as you are this
afternoon and apologies I have apologies
from uh Chris Jan a auditor from audit
New Zealand he felt that um he had
discussed with the finance uh with the
risk and insurance committee last week
at at length and um he was rather busy I
think we were one of three signing today
that he had um it is with
uh some pleasure that actually I give
you um an annual report for adoption
that shows a significant Improvement in
both a non-financial performance
measures um since last year but also
shows a maint um maintaining of our
capital
expenditure um over the last two years
Council has invested just under $100
million in their capital projects that
is more than it had done for the four
years
before that so um we are investing in
capital and and delivering and uh when
we're putting together the achievements
which are outlined in the uh annual
report we um we're starting to we're
struggling to fit them on a page um we
are delivering much more than what we um
have done in Prior Years and we're
bringing that to
you there is however a deficit a
financial deficit um as a result
principally for Council it's a result of
depreciation um when we sat here in
March adopting the 2022 financials we
had an asset revaluation of 215
million that in turn meant a
depreciation went up by $10 million a
year and that's the large part of the um
of the deficit that we're
showing um we have had some ups and
downs along the way we have revalued the
roading assets again just because
inflation is um not helping us at the
moment in relation to our asset value so
they're going up so we revalued the
roading assets and that's a $5 million
increasing the value of those in one
year as probably smaller asset base so
it is becoming an issue that we may have
to revalue one of our waters for the
next Financial year in order to main try
and maintain um audit
compliance there was uh two
qualifications to the audit opinion so
the draft audit opinions included in the
agenda I do have a signed audit opinion
now um one is in relation to
the value of the opening balance of the
comparative numbers so this goes back to
our
2021 um qualification on around asset
values the other is in relation to a
non-financial performance measure which
was a road travel smoothness measure
which is seen as a measure of the
quality of how easy it is to travel
around the city roads that is more
because we had a data Integrity issue
and it could not be audited so they have
uh said that they couldn't give an
opinion on that we couldn't find an
alternate way of auditing that
particular measure
so we have taken the qualification and
we'll look at some data Integrity
improvements from that um there is no
other the other the technical issues
that we had going into it were in
relation to the valuation of in the
investments in inle central limited and
the loan um the
loan um has been ordered to happy with
how we've treated it in the an report we
have taken a provision for potential
non-repayment of that loan it's a
technical accounting thing um that we
has to be assessed every year that we
have that loan and it is done as at 30
June so before any re um refinancing of
the loan had been discussed or was
known the other um aspect was in
relation to the investment in I which is
held by
inago um City Holdings Limited they had
uh reduced the value of that investment
and that's been taken through into the
group so if anybody's looking at the
group Financial result that is a deficit
after tax of over 50 million principally
the result of the write down of the
investment in in Vago Central limited
and the depreciation coming through from
Council so group before we did that
write down was pretty much on par with
last year um that write down we had to
do from a um Accounting Standards
perspective and was following what had
happened from the Holdings company on a
consolidation
basis but the one thing that I would
like to say is I want to thank both my
team and audit New Zealand it's been a
very different audit than we've had in
Prior years um we have changed
internally how we've done stuff but AIT
New Zealand have also adapted and worked
with us um which has been great and the
team have they spent a lot of time
actually in cargle which made it a much
easier process and yes we did have
nearly more Auditors than we had
accountants in the building for some
weeks which was the challenge but we
have been able to work through
that thanks for that um certainly my
reflection is that the share has been
very good um for those who weren't here
at the end of the last audit um it was
horrible me to be done by the 31st of
October we got it in February I think
from memory um and I got so frustrated
at the end of it that I just took a
position I wasn't going to sign the
annual report which meant there'd be a
report to go to Parliament and I just
thought that would trigger some high
level discussion above the audit of
General um and that wording got out to
some of my colleagues of which there
were 30 councils at that stage that
hadn't been done by February um so that
generated a
overnight um Frontage here of some
senior players in a New Zealand the uh
audit has changed and the current Bunch
are really good um to the extent that
they're so paranoic about getting it
done on the 31st that they wouldn't inch
it out 7 days so we could get that data
on the rating so that's how critical it
was for them to be seen to be doing it
knowing that we were potentially a
squeaky door come local government New
Zealand thing so that was really
positive uh just two things about the
report on page
2 58 on there um you've still got uh
Southern Museum and art gallery trust as
a
CCO at 30 June it was still a CCO okay
yep well that answers my other question
which was the the council committees um
would in the future need to reflect the
chief
Executives whatever it is performance
monitoring committee as well but that's
just something for the
future okay any uh questions in relation
to that
Tom um yeah again I'll try to turn your
question but
the adoption of the annual report is
probably the most important governance
accountability that any governance group
has whether it's a council or a a board
legal accountability that we have I have
never known that to happen ever in any
board I've ever been on without the
Auditors being
either present or on Zoom to answer
questions and and and I just I mean is
how unusual is that I've honestly never
known that to happen before
it it is um I have known it to happen on
the 31st of October before where the
Auditors have not been able to be
present because of competing priorities
it is um unusual but probably should be
seen as the fact that the um audit team
spent some time with uh the risk and
insurance committee yeah last week and
it just seems to me it treats the
council as a Rober stamp but actually
all the legal accountability does not
set we AIT and risk it sits with Council
then that yeah that's
true so I'll I'll leave I'll leave the
for you Patricia or Michael to feedback
to the Auditors the other issue I have
is the escalating cost of the annual
audits so as we go forward we have eye
watering amounts coming towards us and
using a very simple
process this is what we get ordered on
each year the auditor general said
there's some new criteria up here and
the question that I am going to ask
through local government New Zealand and
potentially directly to the auditor
general or any MP I can get a hold of is
to say we can't afford this extra cost
it runs to hundreds of thousands of
dollars and what I'm going to suggest
them is look you you you've looked at
this for the last 10 years if that
bottom cluster you found nothing wrong
and it's not a significant risk area for
us why do you keep monitoring it
annually why couldn't you monitor it
every 3 years for home sake which means
that you've got more capacity to do work
here without a huge amount of additional
cost so I am going to ask that question
because I just think this industry is
creating a huge amount of uh costs that
come on to us
Ry at the uh at the risk and insurance
meeting I asked the question um if
because the it does detailed
infrastructure auditing sure that if um
it was of any use then why is New
Zealand's three Waters in such State yep
um when each year it gets audited so you
go back 20 years um so it baffles me
that you can do all this auditing and
make recommendations and keep an eye on
that you're doing things and and the
detail is incredible yet you'd have to
say that 80% of New Zealand 67 councils
have their three Waters in a shopping
State y so why are we paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars yep for this it
just baffled me so I was at that meeting
and I didn't really get an answer did I
no no you didn't and and and I said at
the time
um even though your questions were
making people very uncomfortable it was
the right question to ask I felt because
um when you look at the biggest risk
that we've got in this organization it
is the renewals of three Waters and I
correct if I wrong but I think about
something like about 60 or 70% of what
we spend annually is on is on the three
water Network and renewals that go
forward for that and so for to have an
ongoing audit process that doesn't
recognize there some major shortall in
that um just big as belief really in
some so you know we didn't get it and um
they were very focused on what we we're
not worried about no they didn't say not
worried they said we're not focused on
what you should have spent it's more
focused on what you spend and how you
spend it uh from an audit perspective
and I'm not sure that was all that
helpful because you're quite right we've
got some huge Legacy now and 80% is
probably very conservative it's probably
D something more than that there's not
many councils that are feeling good
about three Waters in the future for
that Grant yeah uh thanks ch um just
some comments really just um I think
acknowledging um the staff's input into
getting this across the line in a very
timely fashion in the way they've
engaged with order New Zealand and a the
had to a New Zealand in terms of their
approach this year particularly versus
last year and to um Bruce's chair I
think Bruce has done a lot of work
behind the scenes as has Michael and
Patricia to sort of keep the wheels of
motion moving along and oiled so that we
can get to this point so I think we need
to acknowledge that um to council pod
just's point I think you know and it's
probably Tom's what Tom's talked to also
you know this documents for us y this
gives us an opportunity for someone
independent coming into our organization
and looking at how a performance is and
where we need to focus and I think you
know maybe some other councils around
the country haven't probably um taken
enough time to look at an audit process
and see where what the M showing them B
so I think you know we are a mer we take
some really good stuff out of this order
as Governors y thank you list me thank
you um Mr Mayor as the person who
cheered the audit and risk I just want
to say it was actually a um strangely
pleasant experience to cheer that
particular audit and risk meeting um
you're a bit of a sad unit have enjoyed
cheering cheering the risk and Assurance
with all of us people have said that to
me over the years about the fact that I
enjoy being on risk committees but I
actually think that they are highly
important yeah um in the in the scheme
of what we are here for as Governors and
that one was a particularly good one to
cheer and I pay all tribute to the usual
cheer Bruce who was unable to cheer it
um and saying that compared with with
last year's um audit and the the tness
that was created largely because of the
attitude of the audit New Zealand
Auditors of the time that was a it was
um as Patricia has reflected quite a
different and much more cooperative and
pleasant approach and the fact that we
had a good result and a I would say a
clean AIT because the two qualifications
let's face it
um one of them is is historic and we are
saying goodbye to it and the other is a
very minor matter of um Road smoothness
the fact that we did actually arrive at
the position we have arrived at was a
very good thing um and to councilor's PO
to councelor P's question I think the
answer really is that the question needs
to be asked
elsewhere um than than the attempt to
ask it from the yeah I will be asking
that and and again as a reflection um
you'll have all seen the media recently
in the last week at one of our
significant Partners in the community
having an assistant manager
that did a significant amount of Fraud
and uh while you sometimes worry about
what you keep checking um there's a huge
amount of reputational damage when that
happens it throws doubt on your ability
to deliver other things you know if
you've if you've missed 88,000 have you
missed a whole lot more um so it's good
to get a really good clean audit report
that covers off all those
things any other comments on the audit
report no I've got a whole Suite of uh
recommendations here seven and all
somebody like to move Leslie move those
and Grant thank you any discussion about
those range of
recommendations being none all those in
favor
carried done somebody would like to now
move that we go to public excluded
Trish and Peter thank
you oh yes all those in favor
Carri